what link does link is a tool it's like
training wheels it gets you to a point
where you can now read a book and not
have to look things up hi there steve
kaufman here
today i want to talk about why
books
are so important in language learning
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
books what do i mean by books i mean
paper books all right now you may be
surprised to hear me say that books are
so important
uh but i'll tell you why i think they're
important and the role of
the computer or
you know iphone ipad
link in language learning and how that
fits in with books
first of all
it's also
a matter of personal preference but if i
have a book
like this
you know i'm not going to be distracted
all right i can't go check my twitter
feed
uh
there's no lights coming at me i'm just
sort of connecting with with whatever is
written in this book uh background of
paper that hopefully isn't glossy i find
that very comfortable i enjoy doing that
i think there is research to show that
we learn better reading from a
traditional source like this rather than
reading on a screen even an iphone
screen or a you know a computer screen
so that's one thing it's comfortable
the second thing about books is
that
it's so important in our language
learning activity in terms of the
content that we use in terms of the
different activities that we have in
terms of the different ways
you know we approach sometimes the same
material
it's very important to have variety
so i like books and i like books where
i'm able to access some of the material
that i've been studying
at link on my ipad for example
so
the the function of the of link
specifically is to get us to a stage
where we can read
a book
in fact the origin of link was that i
was reading
books in spanish and german
and constantly coming across words that
i didn't know
and i would underline them and make
lists and look them up and
then i would stop looking them up and i
would forget them and
it was just very inefficient
what link does link is a tool it's like
training wheels it gets you to a point
where you can now read a book and not
have to look things up
i should add that before link i used to
have you know readers
where there would be a glossary after
each lesson
but here again it's very distracting to
be flipping back and forth to the
glossary the glossary may have the word
that you're looking for very often it
doesn't
on the other hand
um words that have on their glossary
most of them are words you already know
because there's no way the person who
wrote the book can anticipate which
words you know and which words you don't
know
so
in a way
the point of link is is to sort of
bypass that stage of the reader with the
with the vocabulary list and get you to
the point where you can ignore the few
words that you don't know because you
now know 95 of the words so the goal
with link is to make you independent of
link
so
i'm reminded i think there was a parable
by dronzer the taoist chinese
philosopher who said something about
once the fisherman needs the fish trap
to catch the fish and once he's caught
the fish he doesn't need the fish trap
anymore and it went on this i can't
remember what it was but it's a typical
cryptic uh parable
uh i need words for meaning and once i
have the meaning i don't need the words
anymore something to that effect i
should have looked it up in fact i may
just go look for it and link to it from
the description box but the point is
link is that kind of a fish trap it's to
get you to a level where you can read in
books because to me that is the most
enjoyable way to engage with the
language reading is for acquiring
vocabulary
but listening as i've said before is to
get used to the language and even there
you don't want to always have to you
know rely on link to understand what
you're listening to you want to get to
the point i want to get to the point
where i can just go in there pick up my
podcast understand it all
uh watch a movie understand it all so
link is sort of
a range of tools to get to get you to a
point where you can enjoy
the language the way
native speakers enjoy the language and
and a goal
should be to be able to read
books you know i think to myself you
know if
if for whatever reason
the technology around mp3 files and
audio recording and so forth had come
first before
writing and then all of a sudden someone
discovered
the ability to you know
with the sort of
short annotation system writing system
to record what
you know people are saying on paper
let's say we didn't have paper we didn't
have means of writing and all of a
sudden we have it
uh
you know would that would people have
been interested in that or would they
just rely on on audio because after all
historically it was the storytellers who
you know kept literature alive so if you
didn't have to write things down and you
could record it would that mean you
didn't need writing
and i personally would still be
interested in reading i think it's a
wonderful
activity for the brain
to read these symbols and to convert
these symbols into meaning
it's it's a very demanding thing to do
it's a quite a different type of
activity than uh listening to something
and i find that activity is most
pleasant when it is on
paper as opposed to sort of this active
screen with the temptation to fly off
elsewhere so
whenever i see books
um
you know intended for learners of the
language and eventually books you know
intended for native speakers i have a
tendency to buy these you'll see all the
books behind me i got so many of these
books
surprisingly most of them i have read
but many i haven't yet read
and nowadays they are getting a little
better you know so i bought these books
on arabic uh one series is put i don't
have the other one here but one is put
out by yale
and they have a place where you can go
online and get the audio recording
unfortunately they don't give you
you can't download the audio file you
can just listen to it online
i can listen to it on my ipad while i
exercise in the morning but i can't
download it
also they don't give you
the electronic text
and that would of course enable me to
save words and phrases so i could import
it to link go through it with my
training wheels on and link acquire the
words and phrases and then again read it
in the book which is sort of reinforcing
it doing covering the same material but
in a different format which is a
conventional paper
book but they don't do that and that's
been my experience elsewhere that
books like this they will never
facilitate the learning of the language
through their material by enabling you
to access
e-text
or download audio files however another
one
ah here we are this one
because i'm into egyptian arabic so i
found this other series that is put out
by the university of cairo
and it's they've got a tremendous range
a number of audio files which i can
download
uh i i can't access the uh e-text for
these
lessons but i have ordered the books
from amazon
so i'm going to be listening to the
egyptian arabic audio files and then
i'll be looking forward to reading them
on paper
not ideal because as i say the the goal
is to read on paper but i need the
training wheels to get my vocabulary up
to a level where i can enjoy the books
so
i think i sent them an email saying can
i
anyway you could send me the e-text for
these but i don't expect to hear back
because every time i uh email these
publishers i also emailed the yale
bookstore and said anyway i can get the
e-text and the audio files and i don't
expect to hear back
but even without that i find it very
enjoyable to read books in the languages
that i'm learning
even if i have to devise strategies and
and search for resources online
uh to power me up to a point where i can
really you know enjoy those books but
enjoying books real books
printed on paper
is not only a goal but i think it takes
you to that next level
in language learning so
i don't think that
electronic books kindles ebooks are
going to
make uh
paper books disappear so i wanted to
talk a bit about why i think
books are important in language learning
as well as reading for enjoyment
bye for now